This lesson will focus on one of
the quintessential problems of
linear algebra.
Given a set of flat geometric
objects such as lines and
planes, what are their
common intersection points?
In the abstract it isn't immediately
obvious why this problem has much
interest outside of pure mathematics.
How do the intersections of lines and
planes come up in real life?
Geometric objects are often defined to
be sets of points whose coordinates
satisfy a particular relationship,
like an equation.
For example, this ellipse in the plane
is the set of all points x,y
that satisfy the equation 1/4 times x
squared plus 1/9 times y squared = 1.
In this shape in 3 dimensions called a
hyperboloid is the set of all points X,
Y, Z satisfying the equation x
squared + y squared- z squared = 1.
Flat objects like lines and planes
satisfy a special type of equation
called the linear equation In which the
only operations allowed are adding and
subtracting variables and constants and
multiplying variables by constants.
So for example, x + 2y = 1 and
y/2- 2z = x are linear equations.
But x squared- 1 = y is not
linear because x is being
multiplied by x and
y over x = 3 is also not
linear because a variable y is being
divided by another variable x.
In real world situations these equations
typically come from observed or
modeled relationships
between quantities.
Let's take a look at a modified example
from machine learning for trading.
Suppose I'm trading stocks and
I have a choice of two stocks, A and
B, that I can put into my portfolio.
Let's denote the proportion of each
in my portfolio by w A and w B.
Which are weights between 0, meaning
none of that stock is in the portfolio,
and 1, meaning that the portfolio
is entirely that stock.
Note that wA and
wB have to add up to 1 since any portion
of the portfolio that isn't A must be B.
This gives me the linear
relationship wA + wB = 1.
Each stock also has an associated metric
called its beta value representing
how correlated its price movements are
with those of the overall stock market.
The beta value of my portfolio is
a weighted average of the beta values of
its individual components.
So if the beta value of A is -1, and
the beta value of B is 2,
then the beta value of my portfolio
is wA(-1) + wB(2),
or simplified, 2wB- wA.
Having a beta value of 0
means that the portfolio
is uncorrelated with the market.
So it has minimal market risk.
Suppose I want to choose my weights so
that I minimize market risks.
Then that means I need the weights to
satisfy the equation to wB- wA = 0.
This gives me a second to
linear relationship between
the weights of the stocks
in my portfolio.
In other words, I now have two lines.
Finding what values of wA and
wB satisfy both equations.
In other words finding at what
point the two lines intersect at
tells me what the weights of
the stocks I choose should be
in order to minimize my
portfolios market risk.
Often variables are factors
that are within our control but
which we want to set to correct values
in order to satisfy some constraints.
In the previous example our variables
were the weights of the stocks in
the portfolio.
And we had two constraints that
we wanted the weights to satisfy
in order to achieve some goal.
Interpreting this problem in geometric
language, we created two lines and
we want to find the point
where they intersected.
What we created is called
a system of linear equations.
Finding points that satisfy all
the equations at the same time is called
solving the system.
In practice this is how problems
involving the intersections of geometric
objects come about.
These types of problems show up in
fields as diverse as economics, biology,
chemistry, physics, engineering,
and of course computer science.
In this lesson we will use our tools
from the first lesson on vector
operations to solve this ubiquitous
problem of finding intersections.